thank you all for joining me today my
name is jonathan keller and i have the
privilege of being the director of
product management for the bigquery team
here at google cloud very excited to
have the opportunity to walk you through
a lot of the innovations that we're
working on to help you unlock value from
your data
it's no secret why we're all here the
world has become much more data driven
and every company and every industry is
on their journey to figure out how to
leverage data to drive value
unfortunately though many companies are
still struggling to realize tangible and
measurable value from their data but
they want to learn how to provide better
customer experiences or drive
operational excellence through more
intelligent decision making and improved
processes happy to be here to share with
you many of the innovations that
bigquery is working on to help customers
around the world finally be able to
untap the power of their data
if you're not familiar with bigquery it
is google
google's cloud scale enterprise data
warehouse that sits at the center of our
open platform strategy that delivers
value from data
it of course supports standard sql with
dml it's truly serverless multi-tenant
encrypted durable and ready for the
largest inter-scale internet scale
services and also highly secure
enterprise workloads from gigabytes to
exabytes it is also intelligence with
built-in ml extensibility and support
for in-memory analytics it has a
simplified architecture that unifies
real-time and batch workloads and
supports virtually unlimited number of
analytics use cases and it does this all
with industry-leading reliability and
predictable costs
just to drill into a little bit of how
google is able to uniquely deliver this
value bigquery takes advantage of
google's full stack innovations from
hardware and storages network all the
way up to the software that has been
used to analyze data and search to
analyze data for search and advertising
for over a decade we are not strangers
to big data analytics this full stack
approach allows you to access stateless
compute which enables virtually
unlimited capacity to analyze your data
there's no dedicated vms or no clusters
for you to worry about think about
sizing or trying to manage our unique
network and storage infrastructure
provides incredibly high throughput
making it easy for bigquery to
you analyze exabytes of customer data
every day and support streaming
ingestion of petabytes of data every day
as well
all while providing industry-leading
reliability and now with the recent
natively integrated bi engine we're
leveraging this amazing full stack to
power in-memory and real-time analytics
as well
i wish i had more time to walk you
through everything we are working on to
provide an innovation pace that supports
your business but unfortunately i just
have time to call out a few things from
the number huge number of capabilities
that have been released over the last
few months so whether it's governance
capabilities like our field level
encryption or automatic dlp integration
with bigquery to help you secure your
data or continue to invest in advancing
in data warehouse
machine learning with bqml or powerful
new sql workload management capabilities
we're committed to meeting your
analytics needs
with that quick recap of where we've
been investing i want to pivot to a deep
dive in the areas of investment we're
making to really support your business
building and running applications in the
cloud
such as interoperability support that
breaks down data data and application
silos our migration and management
support for helping you get to the cloud
and save money when you're here and
finally a ton of investments in cracking
that hard problem of really getting
value from data with real time and
predictive analytics
as we think about bigquery's
interoperability it's really not like
any other data warehouse you get a
choice of storage cloud tools engines
and languages
and we make that possible to leverage
all these choices with a consistent
security and governance framework so
whether it is our recent launch of cloud
spanner query federation or the launch
of auto scaling serverless spark
integration which you can learn more
about in the open and integrated data
linux session or some of the new
capabilities i'm going to walk you
through now you get to make the choice
that is right for your business and your
data analytics needs
speaking of choice of cloud we are very
excited to announce the general
availability of bigquery omni for amazon
web services and microsoft azure
most companies have data across multiple
clouds today and that frequently creates
data styles that make it difficult if
not even impossible for analysts to
access and leverage that data bigquery
omni is a flexible cross-cloud analytics
solution that lets you cost effectively
access and securely analyze data across
gcp aws and azure with bigquery omni you
can leverage the familiar bigquery ui
api or standard sql to quickly answer
questions and share results from a
single pane of glass
with net new capability that we are
announcing called cross cloud transfer
you can use standard sql to bring the
results your analysis back to gcp with a
simple copy statement and combine that
data and perform advanced analytics with
something like bqml or aggregate the
data from multiple clouds for looker and
bi tools
bigquery omni is a serverless and
connects directly to your data on aws or
azure
you can securely run analytics on
another public cloud with a fully
managed infrastructure all compute runs
on bigquery omni clusters in the same
aws or azure region as your data storage
to learn more about bigquery omni and
see a demo of our new cross cloud
transfer capability please visit the
data analytics session on multi-cloud
and we encourage you to come give it a
try
in addition to the recent bigquery omni
happy to announce that we are making the
secured lake house architecture a
reality across all three clouds with the
introduction of authorized external
tables it is now possible to have
fine-grained governance and security
permissions on like house data
authorized external tables allow you to
set up a service account for accessing
your data natively in google cloud
storage s3 or azure storage so you don't
have to grant privileges to the raw data
or worry about physical file layout
you can use bigquery's native policy
capabilities to provide table column or
row level security for your data and
data lakes and those policies are
consistently enforced regardless whether
accessing the data through sql data proc
or other engines like spark
net you no longer have to care about
where your data resides or what engine
you're using to access it in order to
provide consistent secure auditable and
even policy driven access to your data
before today bigquery customers have the
ability to create user-defined functions
in sql or javascript and run them
entirely within bigquery and while these
functions are performant and fully
managed from within bigquery customers
expressed an interest and desire to
extend bigquery udfs to their own
external code
we had requests from healthcare
providers who wanted to bring their
existing security platforms to bigquery
financial institutions that wanted to
enrich their bigquery data with
real-time stock updates and data
scientists who wanted to be able to use
vertex ai alongside with dqml
to help these customers extend bigquery
into other components we created
bigquery external functions
bigquery external functions provides a
direct integration with cloud functions
gcp's serverless execution environment
for single purpose functions with
external functions in bigquery you'll
now be able to write a function in node
python go java.net ruby or even php and
executed on columns passed in from
bigquery sql queries
bigquery external functions let you
incorporate bigquery sql functionality
with software outside of you query we've
started we've already started working
with key partners like protegrity on
using external functions as a mechanism
to merge bigquery into their security
platform
which will help us help our mutual
customers address their stringent
compliance controls
also happy to announce the preview of
analytics hub which will help
organizations publish discover subscribe
and share data assets they can seek
broader insights and ask bigger
questions bigquery has had
cross-organizational data sharing in
place capability since inception and we
have thousands of organizations sharing
hundreds of petabytes of data today
however analytics hub makes that
experience of discovery and management
much easier analytics hub will allow
publishers to create exchanges that
combine unique google data data sets
with commercial industry data sets and
public data sets publishers will be able
to curate data exchanges internally and
externally and they'll be able to view
aggregated usage metrics on how popular
their exchanges are
with other interoperability capabilities
i mentioned it will soon be possible to
share data in the analytics hub in place
from your data into data lake as well
in addition to the unique google data
that we are working to bring to
analytics hub such as the recent release
of google trends data which enables
discovery of top search terms across
locations we're also partnering with
cross informatics to accelerate access
to data and on data on analytics hub
data providers across finance geospatial
retail and more are all bringing their
data to bigquery and delivering it
through analytics hope we will announce
more partnerships as we closer to
general availability of analytics hub
next year
deciding to move to the cloud is a big
commitment both in tech processes and
change management and knowing that is
the right choice for your business both
for the capabilities and locks but also
for the overall tco is equally important
happy to highlight some capabilities
we're invested in that make all aspects
of moving your data warehouse to the
cloud and to be query on gcp a good bet
i'm excited to introduce the bigquery
migration service a comprehensive
solution for migrating
data to bigquery
which will enable fast and low risk
migrations the bigquery migration
service speeds up teradata to bigquery
migrations with predictable tooling for
customers and partners which cover
migration planning data transfer
automatic sql script conversion and data
verification
support for data additional data
warehouses is also coming soon
one of the hardest pieces of any data
warehouse migration is modernizing
legacy business logic like sql queries
scripts and stored procedures
the bigquery migration service provides
fast semantically correct and human
readable translations of legacy objects
with no ongoing dependencies
it supports a broad range of teradata
artifacts including dml ddl and btec and
translations can be run in batch mode or
ad hoc directly from the bigquery sql
workspace
customers like walmart and ricardo libre
have used it to successfully translate
millions of queries and we encourage you
to come give it a try
when doing analytics at scale
understanding what is happening and
being able to take action in real time
is critical and many of our customers
also desire capacity management
capabilities to optimize their bq
environments
we're happy to launch a new bigquery
administration hub experience with new
features such as research charts and the
slot estimator the capabilities help our
admin users to understand and manage
their bigquery environments like never
before
research charts provide a native
out-of-the-box experience for real-time
monitoring and troubleshooting of your
bigquery environments
these charts make it easy to understand
your historical patterns across slack
consumption job concurrency and job
performance
allowing you to take actions to ensure
your bigquery environment continues to
run smoothly this is now generally
available for all customers that
purchase slot reservations
many customers with pre-purchase
capacity also want to understand should
i buy more or do i have too many slots
would additional slots affect my job
performance the slot estimator is an
interactive capacity management tool
that helps administrators estimate and
optimize their bigquery capacity based
on jobs performance
it looks at historical usage and helps
customers make capacity planning
decisions
it also provides estimates on price for
performance when adding or reducing
slots this is now available for public
preview for all reservation customers
in addition to the admin tooling
sometimes customers have one off or
spiky workloads and flex slots can be a
great solution
in fact many customers have been
leveraging flat flex slots to scale up
or down their environments via simple
sql statements this is great for one-off
batch workloads but does require you to
estimate and manage your capacity we're
now happy to announce the preview of the
flexslot autoscaler autoscaling enables
customers to take full advantage of
bigquery's elastic serverless
architecture while maintaining controls
over cost
with auto scaling you simply set the
size of the environment you're willing
to scale up to and then bigquery looks
at your current query load and if more
budget is available and more capacity
would accelerate your queries in flight
it scales up your environment on the fly
in very small increments by adjusting
the size of your environment every few
seconds you get maximum performance
without any wasted capacity up to your
budget
customers like snap have been using this
to provide phenomenal performance for
their analysts and we've had customers
scale up tens of thousands of slots for
incredible performance on really large
workloads
in addition to the great capabilities
we've announced for managing your query
resources we're also adding additional
support for managing your storage
snapshots currently in preview provide
read-only point-time versions of tables
without actually having to copy the base
data and incur duplicate cost
they can be really useful for logical
backups saving the state of something
like a financial dashboard to keep
points in time and many other use cases
clones coming soon provide modifiable
versions of tables without having to
copy the base data as well this makes it
possible for you to test things like
schema evolution where you're modifying
columns for the rollout of a new version
of your application or to set up dev
test environments that work end to end
so you can run queries on a large amount
of data without incurring the cost of
duplicate data just for a test
environment
once you're in the cloud it's time to
really leverage the capabilities that
have been unlocked that will enable you
to drive your business and really drive
value from that data
happen to highlight some of the
investments across the full stack from
high throughput investment to bi and
tooling and ml that will help you unlock
value from data
for customers with needs for real-time
data analytics the new bigquery write
api is now generally available this new
rate ipa underscores our engineering
innovation to bring industry-leading
performance for streaming ingestion
with over one gigabyte per second of
ingestion throughput enabled by default
and the ability to scale to a hundred
times or more that the right api allows
you to unify streaming and batch
congestion and offers exactly once
delivery semantics it also supports
stream level transactions and automatic
detection of target schema changes
these features combined with native
integration with the data flow will
allow you to accelerate your real-time
analytics workloads
it's also i'm also happy to tell you
that all this net new value over the
previous streaming api
yet it's priced at 50 cheaper than the
current offering so we encourage you to
move to the new bigquery right api
bigquery is a powerful analytics engine
that provides great performance on
calculations aggregations for data at
any scale
however the way customers use bigquery
has expanded from traditional data
warehouses or data lakes today natalix
and today there are many applications
built on bigquery that may not want to
crunch numbers but simply return a
handful of rows associated with specific
data point like a name or an ip address
customers expressed that when finding
these specific data points and terabytes
or petabytes of data it was slower and
maybe even more cost expensive than the
applications were designed for this
because bigquery needs to do a full
table scan and read all the data just to
find the rows associated with the unique
element
to help customers build these
operational applications on top of
bigquery we are announcing new search
capabilities in bigquery customers can
now create search indexes for a table
that accelerates the speed at which you
can identify the rows that contain
specific text
you can use bigquery search indexes in
preview today if you have scenarios that
would benefit from speed up of point
lookups or another way search indexes
are useful when you need to find a
needle in a haystack
search indexes can be used across
multiple columns at once so even if you
don't know exactly where the data is
stored it can still be found it's also
fully integrated with our native json
data type also in preview meaning that
you can search for fields and values and
data that is unstructured or has a
constantly changing structure
these search indexes also back our new
log analytics application that was
recently announced for cloud logging
which helps use bigquery to better
understand your telemetry and data
like the rest of bigquery these search
indexes are fully managed in serverless
google does all the resource
provisioning tokenizes the data and
loads the index behind the scenes so
once you create a search index on a
table you can start streaming data in
and know that your search indexes will
automatically be refreshed without any
management overhead
we've been working with our customers on
this feature who started testing it for
a variety of different use cases for
example a major retailer has found that
they are improving dashboards that have
highly selective inventory items that
they need to slice and dice
we've also worked with several companies
in the uh are hoping to use search
indexes to dramatically reduce costs for
their gdpr processes since they are now
able to touch only the rows that contain
specific individuals without no longer
having to copy
no longer having to query the full data
set for each gdpr request
and of course we found a myriad of other
improvements for log analytics
applications that can now use bigquery
for efficient lookups of things like ip
addresses error codes emails and urls
we were one of the first to bring
integrated machine learning into the
data powerhouse with bigquery ml
and we continue to see tremendous
adoption and customer innovation because
of the ease of use ability to unlock ml
with only a few lines of sql and no
infrastructure management
in addition to continued investment in
additional models and capabilities like
xt boost automl tables and
hyperparameter tuning i wanted to
highlight our work around a couple areas
first off explainable ai
explainable ai helps you understand the
results that your predictive machine
learning models generate by defining how
much each feature contributes to the
predictable
to the predicted result this is referred
to as feature attribution this
information can be used to verify the
model is behaving as expected
to recognize bias in your models and to
inform ways to improve your model and
your training data we support both local
and global explainability
we're also investing in integrating bqml
and vertex ai closer together so you can
leverage the best of both ml apps best
of both ml ops deployments for example
bqmo models will be registered in vertex
and they can be used in managed versions
and compared there
we'll also be adding support in vertex
pipelines so all bqml training
prediction will be possible through
vertex pipeline components so this user
can continue to use their favorite
notebook and use bql pipeline components
to devote training and prediction
overall in partnership with the vertex
ai team we're committed to delivering a
powerful and fully integrated ml
solution with great ease of use
finally happy to announce the launch of
bigquery's bi engine our solution for
enabling data and business analysts to
perform interactive analytics in real
time and with high concurrency
bi engine is not a cache it is a fully
distributed highly available in-memory
database engine which is natively
incorporated into standard bigquery apis
innovatable sub-second queries on large
data sets with high concurrency and can
eliminate the need to manage bi servers
or etl pipelines and it natively works
with sql and bi tools such as looker
tableau power bi etc
for ga we added support for pin pinning
preferred tables in memory up to one
terabyte of memory prevent per
reservation and additional drawing
operations and support for streaming
this means that in combination with the
new rad api for high throughput
streaming materialized views which have
also been recently released and bi
engine for acceleration of interactive
analytics these technologies all work
together to make the vision of always
fresh always fast analytics a reality at
any scale
that was quite the whirlwind tour of
what's new with bigquery thank you for
joining us today and i hope you can see
our commitment to provide powerful
analytics solutions that will help drive
your businesses forward and help you
unlock data
if you'd like to learn more here are
some additional sessions i suggest you
take a look at to see the power of omni
serverless spark streaming log analytics
and secure data for data classification
with google cloud thanks again for
joining me to learn more about bigquery
and i hope we can help you drive
your business and data analytics for
your company forward thank you
you